Good morning. Hank. It's Tuesday.
So I'm on vacation on the shores of Lake Michigan
and last night Twilight looked like this.
I learned yesterday that the first half hour or so after the sun sets
is called Civil Twilight, because it's considered by some
governments to be legally still daytime.
Like centuries ago,
nighttime burglary was often considered a more serious crime than daytime burglary,
and criminals would sometimes seek lesser sentences
by claiming that they robbed a house not at night, but during Civil Twilight.
I just love that phrase Civil twilight,
the adjective Civil makes almost every noun better except war.
Anyway,
I've been thinking a lot about sunsets this week
because the ones here in Michigan
are so ostentatiously beautiful, like back home in Indiana
The light often gets gray and then grayer until it's dark.
But here in Michigan, at least at this time of year these sunsets are mundane
They're ordinary which also makes them cliche of course
I mean the beauty of sunsets and the Civil Twilight's that follow is by now
So cliche that it's difficult to say anything interesting about them like I love E. E. Cummings famous sunset poem which goes: who are you little
eye, 5 or 6 years old peering from some high window at the gold of November Sunset and
Feeling that if day has to become night. This is a beautiful way
It's a good poem
But it only works because Cummings situates the observation in childhood when one is presumably too innocent to have yet realized
How lame it is to write about sunsets and yet a good sunset is beautiful and better still
universally so like our ancestors didn't eat like us or travel like us their relationship to ideas as
Fundamental as light and time were vastly different from ours
but every human who's lived more than a Few years on this planet has seen a beautiful sunset and paused to spend one of the
Last moments of day to be grateful for and overwhelmed by the light, but even now I'm swimming in sentimental waters
How do you celebrate a sunset without being cheesy maybe
stated in cold facts? So here's what happens before a beam of sunlight gets to your eyes it has millions of
interactions with molecules that cause the so-called
Scattering of light different wavelengths are sent off to different directions when interacting with say oxygen or nitrogen in the atmosphere
But at sunset the light travels through the atmosphere
Longer before it reaches our eyes so that much of the blue and purple has been scattered away before it reaches us
I think it's helpful to know how sunsets work
And I've never bought the romantic notion that scientific understanding somehow robs the universe of its beauty
But it still doesn't communicate much about how I felt looking at this absolutely routine
Totally un-extraordinary Civil Twilight
How it felt to look at something that was as beautiful as it was
Normal and to be comforted both by the beauty and the normalcy so anyway I tried to photograph it because you know that's what people
do but of course the camera couldn't capture how I felt in the space between yesterday and last night and
Apparently neither can my voice over. All I can say is that sometimes the world stops me cold
And I feel my smallness and you'd think that would be sad
But it isn't it only makes me grateful Toni Morrison once wrote that at some point in life the world's beauty becomes enough
You don't need to photograph paint or even remember it it is enough
So I turned off my camera, and it was it was enough
Hank I'll see you on Friday